From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。
OK, give me a level.
好的，给我调下音量。
This is me about how much, how loud I talk.
这是我说话大概的音量，多大声。
Not long ago, one of my coworkers here at the radio show, Neil Drumming, and I took a field trip to Philadelphia.
不久前，我和我们广播节目的同事尼尔·德拉明（Neil Drumming）去了一趟费城。
We're going to Amalgam Comics and Coffee.
我们要去Amalgam漫画咖啡馆。
It's a comic shop.
那是一家漫画店。
It's a comic book store. Yeah, and also, like, a coffee shop.
那是一家漫画书店。没错，同时也是一家咖啡馆。
No, no. I got that from the name.
不，不。我从名字就看出来了。
[CHUCKLING] Yes. But it's, I think, the first comic book store owned by a black woman on the East Coast.
[轻笑] 是的。但我认为它是东海岸第一家由黑人女性拥有的漫画书店。
On the East Coast? We have to add that?
在东海岸？我们必须加上这个限定吗？
I think we do.
我想我们得加上。
We're here because recently Neil has gotten really interested in Afrofuturism. And there's this whole intersection between Afrofuturism and comic books. The founder of something called the Afrofuturism Network is speaking at this comic store on this particular day.
我们来这里是因为尼尔最近对“非洲未来主义”（Afrofuturism）非常感兴趣。非洲未来主义和漫画书之间存在着某种交集。今天，所谓的“非洲未来主义网络”的创始人在就在这家漫画店演讲。
And what exactly is Afrofuturism? Neil's been prepping for this question.
究竟什么是非洲未来主义？尼尔一直在为这个问题做准备。
I don't know. There's-- there's, like, a long-winded academic Wikipedia explanation, which I've never even been able to internalize or remember, honestly, if we're being honest. What I like about Afrofuturism, it just seems very-- it's like this way of talking about black people in a way that's really hopeful. It's this idea that we would be engaged in the same kinds of things that, you know, science fiction writers have always talked about-- that we would be engaged with technology, that we would have a future in space, that we would master time travel, that we would have a future in Utopian or Dystopian landscapes. It's like--
我不知道。呃……有一种冗长的学术性维基百科解释，老实说，如果坦诚一点的话，我从来都没能真正理解或记住它。我喜欢非洲未来主义的地方在于，它看起来非常……这是一种以真正充满希望的方式谈论黑人的方式。它传达了这样一种理念：我们会参与到那些科幻小说作家一直谈论的事情中——我们会参与科技，我们在太空中拥有未来，我们将掌握时间旅行，我们将在乌托邦或反乌托邦的景观中拥有未来。这就像……
So partly this is about science fiction. That's really just the tip of the iceberg. And the science fiction part is meaningful because, while there have been black characters in sci-fi for a while now, they're almost never the protagonists. They're never the ones driving the action. And for so long, in so many imaginings of the future, in so much science fiction, there were no black people at all-- which, as Neil points out, makes no sense. He says, you can tell black people are going to make it into the future because they've survived so much already over the centuries.
所以这部分与科幻小说有关。那其实只是冰山一角。科幻小说部分之所以有意义，是因为虽然科幻作品中已经有一段时间出现黑人角色了，但他们几乎从不是主角。他们从未主导剧情。在很长一段时间里，在对未来的许多想象中，在太多的科幻小说中，根本就没有黑人——正如尼尔指出的那样，这完全没道理。他说，你可以看出黑人注定会走向未来，因为几个世纪以来他们已经在如此多的困境中存活了下来。
One of the things that's sort of really specific about Afrofuturism that I like is that it takes into account the past in a lot of ways. It imagines that, you know, black people have forms of survival through, you know, the slave trade, through persecution, that that's almost a technology in itself, the ways in which we've come through those things.
非洲未来主义中我特别喜欢的一点是，它在很多方面都考虑到了过去。它设想……你知道，黑人通过奴隶贸易、通过迫害所形成的生存方式，本身几乎就是一种技术，是我们熬过这些苦难的方式。
Oh, I see. The survival skills.
哦，我明白了。生存技能。
Yeah. And that everything that's been a part of our culture has made it possible for us to pave the way for the future. That's the thing that I like about it, I think-- the feeling like, despite whatever trials or travails you've come through, that you will exist in the future. That just kind of makes me-- it makes me kind of, like, love being black. It makes me feel what I love about being black-- like, oh yeah, you know, we can get through this.
是的。我们文化中所有的一切都使我们能够为未来铺平道路。我想这就是我喜欢它的地方——尽管经历了无论什么样的磨难和艰辛，你都会在未来占有一席之地，这种感觉。这让我……这让我有点，就像，爱上身为黑人。这让我感受到我热爱身为黑人的原因——就像，哦是的，你知道，我们可以渡过难关。
Things I've known about forever, Neil says, are now called Afrofuturism. Old-school stuff, like Parliament-Funkadelic's pimped-out trippy rides to outer space, which predates the term by 20 years.
尼尔说，我一直都知道的事情，现在被称为非洲未来主义。老派的东西，比如Parliament-Funkadelic乐队那种打扮得花里胡哨、飞往外太空的迷幻之旅，这种概念比这个词的出现早了20年。
(RAPPING) All right, Starchild. Citizens of the universe, recording angels, we have returned to claim the pyramids. Partying on the mothership. I am the mothership connection.
（饶舌）好的，星之子。宇宙的公民们，记录天使们，我们已归来夺回金字塔。在母舰上狂欢。我是母舰连接者。
And lately you see lots of famous black people excited about Afrofuturism. Rihanna and Solange appear in black space-age fashion. The director of Selma and 13th, Ava Duvernay, is making a TV series based on a novel by the woman who is kind of a godmother to the movement-- sci-fi writer Octavia Butler. That's after Duvernay finishes the science fiction classic A Wrinkle in Time, with black actors in lots of the leads.
最近你可以看到很多著名的黑人对非洲未来主义感到兴奋。蕾哈娜（Rihanna）和索兰格（Solange）穿着黑人太空时代的时尚服饰出现。《塞尔玛》（Selma）和《第13修正案》（13th）的导演阿娃·杜威内（Ava DuVernay）正在制作一部根据一位女性小说家的书改编的电视剧，这位作家算是该运动的教母——科幻作家奥克塔维亚·巴特勒（Octavia Butler）。在那之前，杜威内刚刚完成了科幻经典《时间的皱折》（A Wrinkle in Time），其中大量主演都是黑人演员。
Donald Glover's last Childish Gambino album was a tribute to Parliament-Funkadelic. And Janelle Monae's tour a couple of years ago was a whole sci-fi stage show with men in lab coats and a story about androids. She sings about spaceships.
唐纳德·格洛弗（Donald Glover）的最后一张Childish Gambino专辑是对Parliament-Funkadelic的致敬。而加奈儿·梦奈（Janelle Monae）几年前的巡演是一场完整的科幻舞台秀，里面有穿着实验服的人和关于机器人的故事。她歌唱着宇宙飞船。
(SINGING) Baby, ooh. l'll reprogram your mind. Come on, get in. My spaceship leaves at 10. Oh!
（唱歌）宝贝，哦。我会重新编程你的大脑。来吧，进来。我的飞船10点出发。哦！
And comics-- Neil and I were in Philadelphia for comics, after all. The thing that Neil was most excited to see in the comic book store was the new Iron Man, where-- I don't know if you've heard this-- in the comics, Tony Stark is in a coma, replaced by a black teenage girl, Genius.
还有漫画——毕竟，我和尼尔是为了漫画才在费城的。尼尔在漫画店里最兴奋看到的东西是新的《钢铁侠》，因为……我不知道你听说过没有……在漫画里，托尼·斯塔克（Tony Stark）陷入了昏迷，取而代之的是一个黑人少女，天才少女。
And she invents a suit that's comparable to Tony Stark's Iron Man suit, which is, like, my favorite piece of fictional technology anyway.
她发明了一套可以媲美托尼·斯塔克钢铁侠战甲的装备，这本来就是我最喜欢的虚构科技。
As he points out, replacing Tony Stark with a black teenage girl, that pierces right into the Arc Reactor heart of the techno superhero sci-fi pantheon.
正如他指出的，用一个黑人少女替换托尼·斯塔克，直接击中了科技超级英雄科幻万神殿那方舟反应堆般的核心。
I mean, think about who Tony Stark, the original Iron Man, is.
我的意思是，想想最初的钢铁侠托尼·斯塔克是谁。
Right.
没错。
He's a wealthy white man. He's, like, a millionaire white guy. He's the unattainable. Like, it's great to have a robot suit and save the world, but how do most people imagine themselves in that context?
他是个富有的白人。他是个百万富翁白人。他是高不可攀的存在。拥有一套机器人战甲并拯救世界固然很棒，但大多数人如何在那种情境下想象自己呢？
Yeah.
是的。
Whereas this girl, her education takes her to this place that a billionaire once was at. Like, that's-- I mean, that's inspiring. It's moving.
而这个女孩，她的教育带她达到了曾经只有亿万富翁才能达到的高度。这……我的意思是，这很鼓舞人心。这很动人。
I don't know. Maybe I'm being-- I've been thinking about it a lot. And like, why has my interest been sparked so much recently? I've always loved science fiction, right? But the idea that, like-- the idea of black people in science fiction appeals to me now because of that notion of telling your own story, because the way black people are talked about, it's often a bleak future.
我不知道。也许我……我最近一直在想这个问题。为什么我最近的兴趣被点燃了这么多？我一直很喜欢科幻小说，对吧？但黑人在科幻小说中的概念现在吸引我，是因为那种讲述自己故事的理念，因为黑人被谈论的方式，通常是一个凄凉的未来。
And a bleak present.
还有一个凄凉的现状。
Yeah, yeah. A bleak present and maybe no future at all, you know what I mean?
是的，是的。一个凄凉的现在，也许根本就没有未来，你懂我的意思吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And so, I mean, think about-- I don't know. I mean, I don't-- maybe not everyone feels this. But I've been watching. There's just a lot of videos of terrible things happening to black people. I mean, it's literally, like, almost a genre. And there's got to be a parallel narrative, you know what I mean? There's got to be a parallel narrative.
所以，我的意思是，想想……我不知道。我是说，我不……也许并不是每个人都有这种感觉。但我一直在观察。真的有很多关于黑人遭遇可怕事情的视频。我的意思是，这真的几乎成了一种体裁。必须有一个平行的叙事，你懂我的意思吗？必须有一个平行的叙事。
And I think for me, the parallel narrative is Afrofuturism. And so, I don't know, it's a way of feeling like-- it's so hard for me to say this without laughing at myself. But it is genuinely hopeful. It's like a way of feeling hope.
我认为对我来说，那个平行的叙事就是非洲未来主义。所以，我不知道，这是一种感觉像……如果不嘲笑自己，我很难说出这句话。但它确实是发自内心的充满希望。这就像一种获得希望的方式。
We sit on a curb way too long talking about this and finally head inside the comic bookstore. It's bright and spacious and smells great, like fresh coffee, decked out in posters for Wonder Woman and Spidey and X-Men and Moongirl. The store was busy because Afrofuturism enthusiast and author William Jones was there to give a lecture on the history of black people in comic books. He popped a slide of a comic book cover from the '60s onto the screen
我们在路边坐了太久来讨论这件事，最后走进那家漫画书店。店里明亮宽敞，闻起来很棒，有新鲜咖啡的味道，到处都是《神奇女侠》、《蜘蛛侠》、《X战警》和《月亮女孩》的海报。店里很热闹，因为非洲未来主义爱好者、作家威廉·琼斯（William Jones）当时正在那里举办关于漫画书中黑人历史的讲座。他在屏幕上放了一张60年代漫画书封面的幻灯片。
This is 1966. Now we have the introduction of the Black Panther-- not affiliated with the political organization. And the reason why I say that is because Marvel Comics recognized that maybe people are going to think we support the Black Panther Party. So they briefly change his name to the Black Leopard. It didn't last, and folks were not buying it.
这是1966年。现在我们迎来了黑豹（Black Panther）的登场——与那个政治组织无关。我之所以这么说，是因为漫威漫画意识到人们可能会认为他们支持黑豹党。所以他们短暂地将他的名字改成了黑豹（Black Leopard）。这没持续多久，而且大家并不买账。
Most of the crowd is black. And nearly every adult Neil and I talked to was familiar with the basic ideas and iconic figures of Afrofuturism, including the owner, Ariell Johnson, a super-energetic 34. She and Neil talked about the subject for a while, and it became clear that for Neil, Afrofuturism is really about the future. But for Ariell, it's about the present, something she sees everyday.
大多数听众是黑人。尼尔和我交谈的几乎每一位成年人都熟悉非洲未来主义的基本理念和标志性人物，包括店主阿里尔·约翰逊（Ariell Johnson），一位非常有活力的34岁女性。她和尼尔就这个话题聊了一会儿，很明显，对尼尔来说，非洲未来主义真正关乎未来。但对阿里尔来说，它关乎现在，是她每天都能看到的东西。
Black people today, black people who are alive and walking around, it's like, we are Afrofuturism. There's a quote that says, "I am my ancestors' wildest dreams." And I think that's true.
今天的黑人，活着的、走动着的黑人，就像是，我们就是非洲未来主义。有一句名言说：“我是我祖先最狂野的梦。”我认为那是真的。
It's like, when we think about our history in this country from when we were first brought here and the condition that they were in, you know, the freedoms that we have now, the things that we are working to accomplish and achieve, those are only things that they could have dreamed about in their wildest dreams. They could not have imagined-- it's like, I own this store, you know what I mean?
就像，当我们想到我们在这个国家的历史，从我们第一次被带到这里，以及当时人们所处的境况，再看我们现在拥有的自由，我们努力去完成和实现的事情，这些都只是他们敢在最狂野的梦里想象的事情。他们无法想象……就像，我拥有这家店，你懂我的意思吗？
So I am Afrofuturism. You are Afrofuturism. The fact that we're walking around, we are defying and challenging stereotypes and negative images.
所以我就是非洲未来主义。你也是非洲未来主义。我们正走来走去的事实，就是在蔑视和挑战刻板印象与负面形象。
It's been a hard week for stereotypes and negative images. And it's been a brutal week for the past returning into the present. Mobs of men carrying torches, people arguing about Confederate statues and George Washington's slaves. It's been a week where lots of us have wondered about the future in this country and where things are going.
这对刻板印象和负面形象来说是艰难的一周。这对过去重返现实来说也是残酷的一周。拿着火把的暴徒，人们争论着南方邦联雕像和乔治·华盛顿的奴隶。在这一周里，我们许多人都对自己在这个国家的未来以及事态的走向感到担忧。
Against that, today, we pose another way to see the world, another way to look at the future and the past that puts it in some context and helps us make sense of things, maybe gives us a little hope.
与之相对，今天，我们提出了另一种看待世界的方式，另一种审视未来和过去的方式，它将其置于一定的背景下，帮助我们理解事物，也许还能给我们一点希望。
I'm joined in the studio right now by my colleague. Neil, hello.
我现在在演播室里和我的同事在一起。尼尔，你好。
Hey.
嘿。
Hey. OK, so my thinking is-- well, our thinking is, since I know really very little about this, about Afrofuturism, and you know, like--
嘿。好吧，我的想法是……或者说我们的想法是，因为我对这个——非洲未来主义——了解得实在太少，而你知道，就像……
I think I know a little bit more, quite a bit more.
我想我知道得多一点，多得多。
OK. So our plan is that I'm going to go away, at least till halfway through the show, and you will stick around.
好的。所以我们的计划是，我会离开，至少直到节目中段，而你会留下来。
Yeah. No, I've just been-- I've been writing pieces and talking to people all over the country about this. So I feel like I have a little bit of a grasp on it.
是的。不，我只是……我一直在撰写文章，并与全国各地的人们交流这件事。所以我感觉我对此有一点点把握。
OK. All right, so I'll see you halfway through. Till then, I'm going to throw some sci-fi here. You have the conn.
好的。好吧，那我们中段见。在那之前，我要抛出一些科幻内容了。指挥权交给你。
I appreciate that. All right, stay with us.
我很感激。好的，请留在我们身边。
Act One, "Metropolis Now." I started really puzzling over Afrofuturism a couple of years ago, when I went to an Afrofuturism conference in New York. Up until that day, I'd mostly heard the term used to refer to musicians like Sun Ra, or to science fiction by Samuel Delany or Colson Whitehead. But at this conference, there were Afrofuturism artists, designers, programmers, filmmakers, fashionistas, healers, yoginis. There was even a woman selling homemade hot pepper sauce in the lobby.
第一幕，“大都会现在”。几年前，我在纽约参加了一次非洲未来主义会议，当时我开始真正琢磨起这个话题。在那一天之前，我大多只听到这个术语用来指代像Sun Ra这样的音乐家，或是塞缪尔·德拉尼（Samuel Delany）或科尔森·怀特黑德（Colson Whitehead）的科幻小说。但在这次会议上，有非洲未来主义艺术家、设计师、程序员、电影制作人、时尚达人、治疗师、瑜伽修行者。大厅里甚至有一位女士在卖自制的辣椒酱。
I began to realize that Afrofuturism wasn't an art movement in the way that I thought of, like, Cubism or Impressionism. It wasn't static or rigidly defined. The people at this conference who were so liberally applying the word were doing so because they thought it made their work seems somehow more active and vital. But I didn't understand exactly how.
我开始意识到，非洲未来主义并不是我想象中那种像立体主义或印象派那样的艺术运动。它不是静态的，也没有僵化的定义。在这次会议上如此随意地使用这个词的人们，是因为他们认为这让他们的作品看起来某种程度上更具行动力和生命力。但我并不完全理解具体是如何运作的。
As the term became more ubiquitous and The New York Times used Afrofuturism to talk about Beyonce's wardrobe changes, I was still trying to figure out the essence of the thing. Like, what makes something Afrofuturist?
随着这个词变得越来越普遍，《纽约时报》甚至用“非洲未来主义”来谈论碧昂丝（Beyonce）的服装变换，我仍然试图弄清它的精髓。就像，是什么让某样东西变得“非洲未来主义”？
I called the woman who'd given the keynote address back at that conference in 2015, activist and writer Adrienne Maree Brown. Adrienne told me that if I wanted to see Afrofuturism that I should visit her hometown, Detroit, Michigan-- a post-apocalyptic city, she'd said. The auto industry is nearly gone, the city's infrastructure is crumbling, many people can't afford basic resources like water and light. It's like the setting for some dystopian sci-fi story.
我给那位在2015年会议上发表主旨演讲的女性打了电话，她是活动家、作家阿德里安娜·玛丽·布朗（Adrienne Maree Brown）。阿德里安娜告诉我，如果我想看非洲未来主义，我就应该去她的家乡——密歇根州的底特律，她称之为“后启示录城市”。汽车工业几乎消失了，城市的基建正在瓦解，许多人买不起水和电等基本资源。这就像某种反乌托邦科幻故事的背景。
As soon as I started reading up on the place, I came across this headline in the Detroit Metro Times. "Inside Ingrid LaFleur's Afrofuturist mayoral campaign." Wow. There was a woman running for mayor of Detroit, and the basis of her platform wasn't socialism or libertarianism. It was Afrofuturism. So I flew out there to hang out with her. I got to hear her do some fundraising, give a speech, talk to some potential voters, and we drove around.
我一读到关于这个地方的报道，就看到了《底特律地铁时报》的这个标题：“深入英格丽德·拉弗勒（Ingrid LaFleur）的非洲未来主义市长竞选”。哇。居然有位女性在竞选底特律市长，而她纲领的基础既不是社会主义也不是自由意志主义。而是非洲未来主义。所以我飞过去和她待了一阵子。我听了她的一些筹款活动，听了演讲，与一些潜在选民交谈，我们还开车到处逛了逛。
And see all the different types of architecture here.
看看这里所有不同类型的建筑。
Ingrid is striking, impeccably styled and glamorous, yet still very bohemian, with a shock of gray in her perfectly coiffed hair. She pointed out her favorite landmarks. We visited a compact urban farm where they make something edible called Afrojam. We rode past a spot in Detroit's North End, where George Clinton's band Parliament-Funkadelic played one of his most iconic albums.
英格丽德令人印象深刻，打扮得无懈可击且时髦，但依然非常波西米亚风格，那一头精心梳理的头发中有着一抹灰色。她指出了她最喜欢的地标。我们参观了一个紧凑的城市农场，在那里他们制作一种名为Afrojam的可食用产品。我们开车经过底特律北区的一个地方，乔治·克林顿（George Clinton）的Parliament-Funkadelic乐队在那里表演了他最标志性的专辑之一。
George Clinton did create the Mothership Connection in Detroit, and he performed it here on Oakland Avenue, which is the street that we're on right now.
乔治·克林顿确实在底特律创造了“母舰连接”，他就在我们现在所在的奥克兰大道上表演了它。
Taking a reporter around and bragging about your hometown is what you'd expect from anyone running for mayor. But it wasn't long before Ingrid the Afrofuturist showed up as well.
带着记者到处炫耀你的家乡是任何竞选市长的人都会做的事。但没过多久，身为“非洲未来主义者”的英格丽德也显露了出来。
The mothership is this wonderful symbol of our future space. And for me, it's this reminder of this empowering future space that can-- the possibilities of that and how it's always present.
母舰是我们未来太空空间的一个美好象征。对我来说，这提醒着我，那个可以带来赋权的未来空间……以及这种可能性的空间，它是如何一直存在的。
We were talking about stuff I knew. I grew up listening to Parliament records too, and reading the comics on the album covers. I always thought it was cool, groundbreaking stuff. But when Ingrid talked about it, she scaled it up to something more grand and spiritual and a little esoteric. To be honest, I found her a bit difficult to follow on this and other topics. But with her enthusiasm, she was just fun to listen to. And anyway, I came to Detroit to find out about Afrofuturism, and here she was-- someone super-eager and ready to talk about it, whether or not what she said made sense to me.
我们谈论的是我知道的东西。我从小也是听着Parliament的唱片长大的，也读过专辑封面上的漫画。我一直觉得那很酷，是很开创性的东西。但当英格丽德谈到它时，她将其提升到了更宏大、更精神、更有一点深奥的地步。老实说，在这一话题和其他话题上，我觉得她有点难以捉摸。但带着她的热情，听她说话本身就很有趣。不管怎样，我来底特律是为了了解非洲未来主义，而这里就有她——一个超级热心且准备好讨论它的人，不管她说的话我是否觉得有道理。
But my orientation, even within Afrofuturism, has always been cosmic. I'm a cosmic person.
但我的导向，即使是在非洲未来主义内部，也一直是宇宙性的。我是一个宇宙性的人。
Here she is discussing time.
这是她在讨论时间。
Time can be defined in 20 million different ways. It can go diagonally up, it can go diagonally down, below our feet-- and just like in the universe, right?
时间可以用2000万种不同的方式定义。它可以对角向上，可以对角向下，在我们脚下——就像在宇宙中一样，对吧？
And here she is on the subject of lunch.
这是她在午餐问题上的观点。
Pleasure has to resonate all through the future, through your movement, into your world. A pleasurable experience for me eating-wise would be eating a great green salad.
快乐必须在整个未来、通过你的运动、进入你的世界中产生共鸣。对我来说，饮食方面的快乐体验就是吃一份很棒的绿色沙拉。
I'm going to time travel a little myself here and let you know that Ingrid LaFleur did not win the primary. She never even got on the ballot officially. When I was there, with the election rapidly approaching, she was still sorting out her policy points. She talked to me vaguely about reviving Detroit's creative economy to rival the glory days of Motown and about the city's litter problem. Two days before the primary, she published a more thorough plan that called for, among other things, a universal basic income for Detroiters paid partly in digital currency. I guess that's pretty futuristic.
我要在这里进行一点时间旅行，告诉你们，英格丽德·拉弗勒没有赢得初选。她甚至从未正式出现在选票上。当我在那里时，选举即将来临，她还在梳理她的政策要点。她模糊地跟我谈到复兴底特律的创意经济以媲美摩城（Motown）的辉煌时代，以及城市的垃圾问题。在初选前两天，她发布了一项更详尽的计划，其中包括为底特律居民提供部分以数字货币支付的全民基本收入。我想那确实相当未来主义。
But at the heart of Ingrid's campaign was an idea that I found far more compelling than any specific policy she put forth. In her plan for Detroit, she writes, "In order to manifest true revitalisation, we must consider the histories and oppressions of the black American population. The foundation of every institution, government, police, education, the museum, was built to silence, disallow, displace, and render powerless black Americans. These institutions were never created for black Americans to truly prosper. It's time for a new plan."
但在英格丽德竞选的核心，是一个我认为比她提出的任何具体政策都更令人信服的理念。在她为底特律制定的计划中，她写道：“为了实现真正的复兴，我们必须考虑到美国黑人人口的历史和压迫。每一个机构的基础——政府、警察、教育、博物馆——都是为了压制、否定、流离失所和剥夺美国黑人的权力而建立的。这些机构从来不是为了让美国黑人真正繁荣而创建的。现在是时候制定一个新计划了。”
That's not something you hear from many politicians. But it makes sense here, because Detroit is 80% black. Fixing the city means fixing it for black people. Ingrid sees Black Americans as the protagonists in the story of Detroit, its future and its past.
这不是你从许多政治家那里听到的声音。但在底特律，这很有道理，因为底特律80%是黑人。修复这座城市意味着为黑人修复它。英格丽德将美国黑人视为底特律故事、其未来和过去的主角。
When I was growing up, people loved to say it was, like, 110% black. It was super-black. It was just black.
当我成长的时候，人们喜欢说它是110%的黑人。它是超级黑的。它就是黑人。
This is the other thing about Ingrid. Maybe she's idealizing, I wouldn't know. But she carries a shining vision of Detroit's past with her everywhere she goes. We drove past vacant houses and empty lots. So much of Detroit is falling apart, neglected or abandoned. But underneath it all, she still sees a vibrant city, populated with a thriving black middle class.
这就是英格丽德的另一面。也许她是在理想化，我不知道。但她带着对底特律过去闪耀的愿景，走到哪里都带着它。我们开车经过空置的房屋和空地。底特律很大一部分正在分崩离析，被忽视或遗弃。但在这一切之下，她仍然看到一座充满活力的城市，有着蓬勃发展的黑人中产阶级。
I grew up walking through this park at dusk. There would be people riding bikes, jogging, playing squash at dusk-- like, it's getting dark. And my mother and I, we felt completely comfortable and safe walking through these woods.
我是在黄昏时分穿过这个公园长大的。黄昏时分会有人骑自行车、慢跑、打壁球——就像，天色渐暗。我和我母亲在穿过这些树林时，感觉非常舒适和安全。
In the car, we talked about Afrofuturism. At one point, I told her about the conference that I'd been to, and how by now I'd heard the word Afrofuturism used to describe everything from comic books to condiments. But it wasn't coming into focus for me. I was starting to wonder if it was just a term for putting a positive spin on anything a black person has ever done or will ever do.
在车里，我们谈到了非洲未来主义。有一次，我告诉她我参加过的那个会议，以及到现在为止，我听过“非洲未来主义”这个词被用来形容从漫画书到调味品的一切东西。但这对我来说并没有变得清晰。我开始怀疑，这是否只是一个给黑人做过或将要做的任何事情加上积极修辞的术语。
Like, I was moved by the optimism that seems inherent in Afrofuturism.
就像，我被非洲未来主义中固有的乐观主义所打动。
Yes!
是的！
But I was also like, if it's everything, then what is the point of it?
但我也觉得，如果它代表一切，那它的意义何在？
But that is the point-- imagining a more healthier present and future, and kind of recontextualizing the past so that it's empowering instead of victimizing. It's our way of not only surviving, but it's also a way of healing within the moment because there's constant traumas that we're dealing with-- historical and present day. So it's a way of allowing ourselves to shape-shift, to accommodate whatever comes our way.
但这就是重点——想象一个更健康的现在和未来，并以某种方式重构过去，使其变得赋权而不是受害。这是我们不仅生存的方式，也是当下治愈的方式，因为我们正在处理持续的创伤——历史和现实的创伤。所以这是一种让我们能够变形以适应任何来临事物的方式。
Ingrid eventually dropped me back at my hotel. Earlier, she'd given me a greasy brown bag containing a cookie which I now finally got around to eating. It turned out to be the most delicious gluten-free cookie I had ever tasted. But I was still feeling hungry and a bit confused by our conversation. Whatever bigger point she had been making about Afrofuturism, I was afraid that it had been lost on me.
英格丽德最终把我送回了酒店。早些时候，她给了我一个油腻的棕色纸袋，里面装着一块饼干，我现在终于有时间吃了。结果那是我吃过的最好吃的无麸质饼干。但我仍然感到饥饿，而且对我们的谈话感到有点困惑。无论她关于非洲未来主义说了什么大道理，我担心我已经错过了。
I went looking for a burger and a stiff drink to mull it over. At a bar, over bourbon, I met a guy that I'm going to call Sam, with dark skin and hints of gray in his sideburns that betrayed his boyish face. He was dressed for a night on the town-- light blazer, Burberry shirt, patterned silk scarf. I asked him and another patron, both Detroit residents, if they'd heard of Ingrid LaFleur for Mayor. They hadn't.
我去找了一个汉堡和一杯烈酒来思考这个问题。在一家酒吧，喝着波本威士忌时，我遇到了一个我姑且称之为山姆（Sam）的家伙，他皮肤黝黑，鬓角带着一丝灰色，背叛了他那张稚嫩的脸。他为了晚上的出游精心打扮——浅色西装外套，Burberry衬衫，印花丝绸围巾。我问他和另一位顾客，他们都是底特律居民，是否听说过英格丽德·拉弗勒竞选市长。他们没听说过。
When Sam got up to pay his check after we'd only been talking for a few minutes, he surprised me by asking if I wanted to go with him to check out some of the other spots around town. I wasn't dressed for it and I'd left my recording equipment in my room, but what the hell? Sam said it was OK for me to describe what happened next.
当山姆聊了没几分钟就起身去结账时，他让我感到惊讶，问我是否想和他一起去看看城里的其他地方。我没为这打扮，而且把录音设备留在了房间里，但管他呢？山姆说我描述接下来发生的事没问题。
Sam had a nice car, a Mercedes. It never cost him more than $10 to park it in a lot. He loved that about Detroit-- parking was so cheap. He'd moved here from New York sometime in the late '90s and fallen hard for the city. As we drove, he talked up the real estate. He talked about his job and the IT business he ran out of his home. Things seemed to be going well.
山姆有一辆好车，一辆奔驰。在停车场停车从来没花过超过10美元。他喜欢底特律的这一点——停车费太便宜了。他90年代末从纽约搬到这里，深深地爱上了这座城市。当我们开车时，他大谈房地产。他谈到了他的工作和他从家里经营的IT业务。事情看起来进展顺利。
We met up with Sam's friend, Rick, a bald, bearded, alpha male type in a reddish leather jacket, and followed him in his new BMW to a place called The Griot. It was the type of establishment once commonly referred to as grown and sexy.
我们见到了山姆的朋友里克（Rick），一个秃顶、蓄着胡须、穿着红色皮夹克的雄性领袖型人物，并跟着他那辆新宝马到了一个叫“The Griot”的地方。那是一类过去常被称为“成熟而性感”的场所。
Rick ordered another round of bourbon and some wings and flirted with the bartender. By now it was clear that these guys were looking to meet women. And that was weird because of this thing that Sam had told me earlier while we were in the car together. He'd said that not too long ago, his wife had gotten sick, and he'd taken care of her for a year. And then she died, leaving Sam and their teenage son with only each other.
里克又点了一轮波本威士忌和一些鸡翅，并和酒保调情。到这时很明显，这些人是想去结识女性。这很奇怪，因为山姆早些时候在车里告诉过我一件事。他说不久前，他妻子病了，他照顾了她一年。然后她去世了，只留下了山姆和他们的十几岁的儿子相依为命。
Sam didn't actually want to be doing what we were doing tonight. This is, like, only his second time out as a single man. He didn't feel ready to meet women, to date. But he also felt like it was time. He couldn't wait forever. So he was doing what he felt like he had to do to move forward.
山姆其实不想做我们今晚正在做的事。这是他作为单身男人第二次出门。他觉得还没准备好去结识女性，去约会。但他同时也觉得是时候了。他不能永远等待。所以他正在做他觉得为了前进必须做的事。
Sam and Rick took me to a few different spots that night. But the one that I remember the most was a place called Floods. From the outside, it looked like a common family restaurant. I thought it was closed until we rounded the corner and saw the cluster of people leaving their cars with the valet.
山姆和里克那晚带我去了几个不同的地方。但我印象最深的是一个叫Floods的地方。从外面看，它看起来像一家普通的家庭餐馆。我以为它关门了，直到我们转过弯，看到一堆人把车交给代客泊车。
Inside, Floods was huge. Sam said it was probably about 2,500 square feet. A massive bar separated two rooms. At one point, there was both a band and a DJ playing simultaneously. And wall to wall, there were well-dressed, grown-up black folks dancing and singing along to classic soul, funk, and R&B. It reminded me of how Ingrid had described the Detroit she grew up in and its thriving black middle class. 110% black, she had said. Super-black, just black.
Floods里面非常大。山姆说可能大约有2500平方英尺。一个巨大的吧台将两个房间隔开。有一个时刻，乐队和DJ同时在演奏。墙内墙外，都是穿着讲究、成熟的黑人们在跳舞，跟着经典灵魂乐、放克和R&B音乐一起歌唱。这让我想起了英格丽德描述她长大的底特律及其蓬勃发展的黑人中产阶级时所说的话。110%黑人，她说。超级黑，就是黑人。
I'd been drinking all night. So yeah, I was already a little in my feelings. But I swear, I teared up at the sight of it all.
我喝了一整晚的酒。所以，是的，我已经有点感性了。但我发誓，看到这一切，我热泪盈眶。
Sam hadn't wanted to come to Floods at first because he thought too many people would recognize him. I think he didn't want to be judged for being out on the town after his wife's death. And when we walked in, he seemed a little uncomfortable.
山姆起初不想来Floods，因为他觉得太多人会认出他。我想他不希望自己在妻子去世后出来消遣而被人评头论足。当我们走进去时，他看起来有点不舒服。
We split up for a while, and later he found me standing in a corner at the edge of the dance floor, mesmerized. He pulled out his phone and showed me the number he had just gotten of a beautiful woman who walked in earlier and drawn quite a bit of attention. Earlier in the day, Ingrid had said a bunch of Afrofuturist stuff to me about Detroit, shapeshifting, and reckoning with its past, and healing. I felt like I was seeing some smaller version of that now with Sam. Most days, he was probably just a guy in some pain, struggling to survive this very traumatic thing that happened. But tonight, in spite of that, Sam was imagining a better future and doing something about it.
我们分开了一会儿，后来他发现我站在舞池边缘的一个角落里，出神地看着。他掏出手机，向我展示了他刚刚要到的一个早些时候进来、吸引了不少注意力的漂亮女人的号码。那天早些时候，英格丽德对我说了一堆关于底特律、变形、审视过去和治愈的非洲未来主义内容。我觉得我现在在山姆身上看到了它的一些微小版本。大多数日子里，他可能只是一个痛苦的人，努力在经历这件非常创伤的事情后生存下来。但今晚，尽管如此，山姆正在想象一个更美好的未来，并为此付诸行动。
He smiled, shouted some words of encouragement at me over the music, and waded back into the crowd. His spirits were up. His evening wasn't over.
他笑了，在音乐声中对我喊了一些鼓励的话，又钻回了人群中。他情绪高涨。他的夜晚还没有结束。
[MUSIC - "RIGHT IN" BY BRYCE DETROIT FEATURING COKO BUTTAFLI]
[音乐 - “RIGHT IN” by BRYCE DETROIT FEATURING COKO BUTTAFLI]
Act Two, "Past and Perfect." So there's this idea that occurs over and over in Afrofuturism that, summed up, basically says, the past is always with us. It affects us. It has the power to make us stronger if we learn how to use it properly.
第二幕，“过去与完美”。所以，非洲未来主义中反复出现的一个理念，总结起来基本就是：过去永远与我们同在。它影响着我们。如果我们学会正确地利用它，它就有能力让我们变得更强大。
Some West African cultures represent this idea with the image of what's called the Sankofa bird. It's a bird walking forward but with its head looking backward, meaning no matter what, we carry the past with us into the future.
一些西非文化用一种被称为“桑科法（Sankofa）鸟”的形象来代表这一理念。这是一只向前走但头向后看的鸟，意味着无论如何，我们都把过去带进了未来。
In one of the most well-known Afrofuturist novels, Kindred by Octavia Butler, the main character finds herself traveling back and forth between her normal contemporary life in the present and the world of her ancestors in the Antebellum South, where she's treated like a slave. And the two time periods start to merge. That's fiction. Our next story is told by a woman who went through a version of that in real life.
在最著名的非洲未来主义小说之一，奥克塔维亚·巴特勒的《希德》（Kindred）中，主角发现自己在现代的日常生活和南北战争前南方祖先的世界之间来回穿梭，在那里她被当作奴隶对待。而这两个时间段开始融合。那是小说。我们接下来的故事由一位在现实生活中经历过类似版本的女性讲述。
When I graduated from NYU with a BA in Drama and a mostly unplanned double major in Anthropology, my mother asked me, what are you going to do with that, act in a museum? This seemed especially rude coming from a sociologist, but she had a point. For the first few years of my adult life, that's exactly what I did.
当我以戏剧学士学位从纽约大学毕业，并意外地获得了人类学辅修学位时，我母亲问我，你打算用那个做什么，在博物馆里表演吗？这对一个社会学家来说显得特别粗鲁，但她说的有道理。在我成年生活的最初几年，我正是这样做的。
During those years, Azie Dungey was living in her hometown, a suburb of Washington DC, working as an actor at night in plays for which she was paid almost nothing. And to make some extra cash for Christmas, she took a gig, time-traveling to the least desirable job of the 18th century. She was a slave, or she played one anyway, performing for tourists at George Washington's estate, Mount Vernon, for weekend events called Mount Vernon by Candlelight.
那些年里，阿兹·邓吉（Azie Dungey）住在她的家乡，华盛顿特区郊区，晚上在薪水微薄的戏剧中担任演员。为了圣诞节赚点外快，她找了一份工作，穿越回到18世纪最不受欢迎的工作。她是一名奴隶，或者说她扮演一名奴隶，在乔治·华盛顿的庄园——弗农山庄（Mount Vernon）为游客表演名为“烛光下的弗农山庄”的周末活动。
The halls of the mansion were decked for Christmas. Visitors would walk through, stopping in each room to meet a character and hear their monologue about the season. There was Mrs. Washington, beloved wife, Dr. James Craik, Washington's physician and best bud, Nellie Custis, sweet-natured granddaughter, and me, Caroline Branham, slave. I had a script that I used to talk about Caroline's life. It was short. Besides the odd "I'm a slave at Christmas too, a slave to my husband and kids" joke from 40-year-old white women, people were interested and respectful.
大宅的走廊装饰着圣诞装饰。游客们走进来，在每个房间停下来见一个角色，听他们讲述关于这个季节的独白。有华盛顿夫人，深爱的妻子；克雷克医生，华盛顿的医生兼密友；内莉·库斯蒂斯，甜美的孙女；还有我，卡罗琳·布兰汉姆（Caroline Branham），奴隶。我有一份用来讲述卡罗琳生活的剧本。这很简短。除了偶尔有40岁的白人女性开玩笑说“我也是圣诞节的奴隶，是我丈夫和孩子的奴隶”外，人们都很感兴趣且尊重。
After Christmas, I decided to stay in the job. It started out fine. The winter weather meant the visitors were mostly local and relatively few. I enjoyed my daily walks on the treelined lanes, soft snow falling on my hooded, mulberry-colored cape, as I looked out at the stunning view of the Potomac River. And when it was too cold, I would stay in the library and read through musty old books and primary source letters and notations that helped me understand this distant world I inhabited and the woman I portrayed.
圣诞节后，我决定留在这份工作中。起初一切都很顺利。冬天的天气意味着游客主要是当地人，人数相对较少。我享受在树木葱郁的小径上散步，柔软的雪花落在我的兜帽桑葚色斗篷上，看着波托马克河令人惊叹的景色。天气太冷的时候，我就待在图书馆，翻阅发霉的旧书、原始资料信件和注释，这些帮助我理解我所居住的这个遥远世界以及我所扮演的那个女人。
I was Caroline Branham, a real woman who had been housemaid to Mrs. Washington. I studied Caroline's life and times for months. And every day, when I put on a beautiful crimson dress with tiny yellow and green flowers, I became her. With each eyelid I laced on my corset, I felt myself get closer to her posture, how her body related to the world. With my hair pulled back in two large French braids under a bonnet, I sat on a bench and set my fingers to the work Caroline did-- rows of stitches on shirts and brightly colored embroidery. I could picture her laying down her head at night, next to her husband Peter and their six children-- Wilson, Rachel, Jemima, Leanthe, Polly, and little Peter. I imagined how she hoped that one day they would wake up in a world better than the one she'd been given.
我是卡罗琳·布兰汉姆，一个曾担任华盛顿夫人女佣的真实女性。我研究了卡罗琳的生活和时代几个月。每天，当我穿上一条带有微小黄绿色花朵的漂亮深红色裙子时，我就变成了她。当我系上紧身胸衣的每一个孔时，我感觉自己更接近她的姿态，她的身体如何与世界相连。头发在帽子下扎成两条巨大的法式辫子，我坐在长凳上，让手指开始卡罗琳做的工作——在衬衫上缝线和刺绣鲜艳的图案。我可以想象她晚上在丈夫彼得和他们的六个孩子——威尔逊、雷切尔、杰米玛、莉安丝、波莉和小彼得——身边躺下时的样子。我想象着她如何希望有一天他们能在一个比她所被给予的世界更好的世界中醒来。
Then spring came, and tourists from around the country started pouring into Mount Vernon. My job was to simply be available to the visitors, to talk to them and answer their questions as Caroline. This time, there was no script. And I realized pretty quickly that just being there, existing as a black woman in that place, was a threat to the fantasy of a noble America. I was the stain on George Washington's white house.
然后春天来了，来自全国各地的游客开始涌入弗农山庄。我的工作只是为游客服务，和他们交谈，以卡罗琳的身份回答他们的问题。这一次，没有剧本。我很快意识到，仅仅待在那里，作为一个黑人女性存在于那个地方，就是对高尚美国幻想的威胁。我是乔治·华盛顿白房子上的污点。
And I watched them grapple with this right in front of me-- me, the least confrontational human being you'll ever meet. I mean, it took me until I was 25 years old to tell my mom I did not liked her baked tofu smothered in Kraft barbecue sauce. Some people were so uncomfortable with me that they bumbled through the first random thing that came to their mind. You're a slave? Oh, OK. So are the vegetables in the garden real? Fake vegetables. This is an outdoor garden. They are literally coming out of the ground, and there's a man standing there watering them.
我看着他们在我的面前努力应对——我，你见过的最不爱争论的人。我的意思是，我直到25岁才告诉母亲我不喜欢她用卡夫烧烤酱炖的烤豆腐。有些人对我很不自在，以至于他们笨拙地胡乱说出脑海中的第一件事。你是奴隶？哦，好的。那花园里的蔬菜是真的吗？假蔬菜。这是一个户外花园。它们确实是从地里长出来的，旁边还有一个男人站在那里浇水。
Or they immediately asked questions with obvious answers that they just hadn't thought through. Why don't you go up to Massachusetts and go to school instead of being a slave, one person asked? Right, as soon as I can get rid of this very obvious brown skin, steal a horse and a map that I can't read, I will be on my way.
或者他们直接问一些有明显答案的问题，而这些问题他们根本没深思过。一个人问，为什么你不去马萨诸塞州上学，而要当奴隶呢？对，只要我能摆脱这非常明显的棕色皮肤，偷一匹马和一张我看不太懂的地图，我就会上路。
Or they'd go into immediate denial mode, like the old woman who out of nowhere yelled at me, George Washington had no slaves. I said, yes, he did. She responded, no he didn't. And this went on, back and forth, until her son got embarrassed and pulled her away.
或者他们会直接进入否定模式，就像那位老妇人，不知从哪里冒出来对我大喊：乔治·华盛顿没有奴隶。我说，是的，他有。她回应说，不，他没有。这来来回回持续了很久，直到她儿子感到尴尬把她拉走。
Or they offered another offense as some sort of defense. But the Irish were slaves too. OK, that's not really true, and what the hell does that have to do with me?
或者他们会提出另一种冒犯来作为某种辩护。但爱尔兰人也是奴隶。好吧，那不是真的，而且那跟我也没半点关系。
And of course, there were those who would take the opportunity to teach me instead. You know, slavery was a good industrious life where you got room and board for your work. Mm-hmm-- a one-room cabin they built themselves with eight people sleeping on a dirt floor and a bag of corn meal every week. Room and board.
当然，还有那些会借此机会教导我的人。你知道，奴隶制是一种勤劳的好生活，你因为劳动而获得了食宿。嗯哼——一个他们自己建造的八个人睡在泥地上的单间小屋，每周发一袋玉米面。食宿。
It was just a bizarre situation to be in, playing Caroline. I'd be sitting next to Miss Nellie in the midst of her roleplay, who'd be going on and on about the lovely letters that her dear grandpapa, George Washington, had written her, or all the fancy soirees that she attended. We'd be in the greenhouse with a gorgeous garden outside on an estate that overlooked the Potomac.
这是一个极其荒诞的情况，扮演卡罗琳。我会坐在内莉小姐旁边，在她的角色扮演中，听她喋喋不休地谈论她亲爱的祖父乔治·华盛顿写给她的可爱信件，或者是她参加的所有华丽社交聚会。我们会在温室里，外面有华丽的花园，庄园俯瞰着波托马克河。
I'd literally hear white visitors sigh, listening to Miss Nellie read from her letters, full of nostalgia for this time long gone. They'd talk about how much simpler things were back then, how touching George Washington's letters were, what a fine man, and how lucky Miss Nellie was to live such a charming life. It was charming. I was charmed by it.
我真的会听到白人游客叹息，听内莉小姐朗读她的信件，对那个早已逝去的时代充满怀旧。他们会谈论过去的生活是多么简单，乔治·华盛顿的信件是多么动人，他是个好人，内莉小姐能过上如此迷人的生活是多么幸运。这确实迷人。我被它迷住了。
Then it'd be my turn. Here's what I talked about-- how my husband is rented from Mrs. Washington's relative and how he could be sent back at any time, how I go home to my cabin at night, hoping that none of my children have been sold, that once my friend was whipped so bad her fingers were torn and she couldn't sew for three weeks-- all real stuff from Caroline Branham's life. One time, an old lady just walked up to me while I was talking, hugged me, whispered "I'm sorry," and walked away. Another time a man handed me a $20 bill, so I guess that was reparations.
然后轮到我了。这是我谈论的内容——我的丈夫是从华盛顿夫人的亲戚那里租来的，他随时可能被送回去；我晚上回到家的小屋，祈祷我的孩子都没有被卖掉；曾经我的朋友被鞭打得手指撕裂，三周都无法缝纫——这些都是卡罗琳·布兰汉姆生活中的真实片段。有一次，一位老太太在我说话时走过来，拥抱了我，低声说“对不起”，然后走开了。另一次，一个男人给了我一张20美元的钞票，我想那算是赔偿吧。
In Caroline's day, there were typically no more than 10 white people who lived in the Washington household at any given time. Meanwhile, there were 316 slaves. And who was there to tell their story? Me. I was the only black actor. So I felt like it was up to me to be all 316 people, to research them too, so I could talk about my friend the blacksmith or Delphi, the wool spinner. I learned so much about being a slave that to this day there is space in my brain devoted to this information. Like, I can tell you how to shine silver with horse urine, which herbs to use to make your owner sick but not kill her, how beating a slave and then dousing them with salt water to disinfect the wounds was called pickling. Pickling-- I hate that I know that.
在卡罗琳的时代，华盛顿家中居住的白人通常不超过10人。与此同时，有316名奴隶。谁在那里讲述他们的故事？我。我是唯一的黑人演员。所以我感觉我有责任成为这316个人的化身，去研究他们，这样我才能谈论我的铁匠朋友或羊毛纺纱工德尔菲。我学习了太多关于成为奴隶的事情，以至于直到今天，我的大脑中仍然留有空间专门存放这些信息。就像，我可以告诉你如何用马尿擦亮银器，用什么草药可以让你的主人生病但又不至于要了她的命，如何鞭打奴隶然后用盐水清洗伤口以防感染被称为“酸渍（pickling）”。酸渍——我恨我知道这些。
As my time at Mount Vernon went on, I began to notice there was something that would happen in particular with white men. It was, like, almost despite themselves, they would act out the power dynamic from 1797. I can remember at least five times when a white man of a certain age sat on a bench way too close to me and said something like, I used to be into a black girl, back when I was young. Then he would pause, presumably waiting for my response. What am I supposed to say to that, exactly, thank you?
随着我在弗农山庄的时间推移，我开始注意到白人男性身上会发生一件特别的事情。他们几乎是不由自主地演绎出1797年的那种权力动态。我记得至少有五次，一位一定年纪的白人坐在我旁边过近的长凳上，说类似的话：我年轻的时候曾经迷恋过一个黑人女孩。然后他会停顿，大概在等我的回应。我到底该对那种话说什么，谢谢你？
Once a man got physical. I was walking down the lane on a particularly hot and busy day when a tall, burly white man grabbed my arm, pulled me towards him, and said, show me where you're branded. I was startled and could only get out the words, sir, I haven't been branded. And then he and his wife began laughing heartily. Well, you got it good up here. We're from South Carolina, and they branded them down there. Girl, you got it good.
有一次有个男人动手动脚。在一个特别炎热繁忙的日子里，我沿着小径走，一个高大壮实的白人抓住了我的胳膊，把我拉向他，说：让我看看你在哪里被烙印了。我吓了一跳，只能说出：先生，我没有被烙印。然后他和他的妻子开始大声嘲笑。好吧，你在这里过得不错。我们来自南卡罗来纳州，他们在那里确实会烙印。女孩，你过得挺好。
And then one time, one of the guys I work with, also in costume, wearing a tricorn hat, he and I were walking from the farm back to the mansion, and we decided to take the forest trail. We were having a nice, normal conversation when out of the blue he says, hey, let's re-enact a slave rape. You tear up your clothes a little bit and go running out the forest screaming, and I'll follow behind you pulling up my pants.
还有一次，我和一起工作的一个同事，他也穿着戏服，戴着三角帽，我们要从农场走回大宅，决定走森林小径。我们正在进行正常的谈话，他突然说：嘿，我们重演一场奴隶强奸吧。你把衣服撕破一点，从森林里尖叫着跑出来，我跟在后面提裤子。
He laughed. I didn't say anything. I just sort of tittered. I [BLEEP] tittered. That's an old-timey, fancy way of saying I laughed with the bastard. I laughed because I didn't know what else to do, because I felt completely and utterly powerless.
他笑了。我没说什么。我只是轻笑了一声。我[哔]轻笑了一声。这是一种老派、做作的说法，意思是我和那个混蛋一起笑了。我笑了，因为我不知道该怎么办，因为我感到彻底且完全的无力。
I started calling in sick a lot because I was sick a lot. My stomach would twist and turn. I would sometimes get a choking feeling and cough as if to vomit, but nothing was there. I had terrible headaches, and I couldn't do anything but sleep. And one day it occurred to me that Caroline felt this way too, this exact way. The farm manager who oversaw slaves on the Mansion House Farm noted that Caroline, quote, "complained of a pain in her head and side," and had, quote, "a very dry bad cough."
我开始经常请病假，因为我真的经常生病。我的胃会翻江倒海。有时会有哽咽感，咳嗽得好像要呕吐，但什么都没有。我有严重的头痛，除了睡觉什么也做不了。有一天我突然意识到，卡罗琳也有这种感觉，一模一样的感觉。负责大宅农场奴隶的农场经理记录道，卡罗琳引用说“抱怨头和侧部疼痛”，并且引用说“咳嗽非常严重”。
George Washington's friend, Dr. Craik, is recorded as having treated her for such bad stomach pains that he had to bleed her, give her stomach drops, and prescribe 20 pills for bowel obstruction. My job was to inhabit Caroline's life, but she started inhabiting mine.
华盛顿的朋友克雷克医生被记录在案，曾因她严重的胃痛而不得不为她放血、滴胃药，并开了20粒肠梗阻药。我的工作是进入卡罗琳的生活，但她开始进入我的生活。
I had this weird sensation that I was living in multiple time periods at once, like the Sankofa bird. I started seeing Mount Vernon everywhere in the modern world. An evolutionary psychologist wrote a blog post for Psychology Today, where he claimed that he objectively proved that black women are the least attractive of all races of women with science. This happened in the year of our Lord 2011.
我有这种奇怪的感觉，我同时生活在多个时间段，就像桑科法鸟。我开始在现代世界各处看到弗农山庄。一位进化心理学家在《今日心理学》上写了一篇博客文章，声称他客观地用科学证明了黑人女性是所有女性种族中最不具吸引力的。这发生在主后2011年。
I saw this only a few days after reading Thomas Jefferson's Notes on the State of Virginia for work. Apparently Jefferson-- who, by the way, was known to have slaves with the lightest skin possible-- had come to the same conclusion about my race and gender over 200 years ago. He said that black men prefer white women, and black women are preferred by orangutans. Oh, so that's why I'm single.
我在为了工作阅读托马斯·杰斐逊的《弗吉尼亚纪事》几天后才看到这个。显然杰斐逊——顺便说一句，他以拥有肤色最浅的奴隶而闻名——在200多年前就得出了关于我的种族和性别的相同结论。他说黑人男性更喜欢白人女性，而黑人女性更受猩猩青睐。哦，所以这就是我单身的原因。
Then, Trayvon Martin. I was watching the news one evening about a black boy harassed and pursued by a white Latino man who was convinced that he didn't belong in his neighborhood. And because of this compulsion, the innocent black boy ended up dead. My heart was in my gut. The first thought that came into my head, he didn't have his pass. Pass? I shook it off. No, that can't be right.
然后是特雷沃恩·马丁（Trayvon Martin）。一天晚上，我看着新闻，一个黑人男孩被一个白人拉美裔男人骚扰和追逐，那个男人坚信他不属于那个社区。因为这种强迫症，那个无辜的黑人男孩最终死了。我的心沉到了谷底。我脑子里浮现出的第一个想法是：他没带通行证。通行证？我摇了摇头。不，那不对。
When a slave left their plantation, they had to carry a pass from their master or overseer saying where they were going and when they were expected to return. Not having your pass, or your free papers if you were free, was dangerous. At any time, any white person could stop you and demand to see your pass. If you didn't produce it, you were thrown in jail. Having black skin alone was enough to make you suspicious, and a white stranger could be the judge and jury of your fate. Trayvon Martin didn't have his pass.
当奴隶离开种植园时，他们必须携带一张来自主人或监工的通行证，说明他们要去哪里以及预计何时返回。没有通行证，或者如果你是自由人，没有自由证，是很危险的。任何白人随时都可以拦住你，要求看你的通行证。如果你拿不出来，就会被扔进监狱。仅凭黑皮肤就足以让你成为怀疑对象，而一个白人陌生人可以成为你命运的法官和陪审团。特雷沃恩·马丁没有带通行证。
There's a thing white people say to black people all the time. I've had it said to me. Why don't you just get over it-- "it" being slavery and all historical oppression. Why don't you just get over it, they say. It's in the past.
白人经常对黑人说一句话。别人也对我这么说过。为什么你不忘掉它——“它”指奴隶制和所有历史压迫。为什么你不干脆忘掉它，他们说。那都是过去的事了。
What I would say to white people in response is that you're not over the past. Every year you flock from all over the country to Mount Vernon and other places like it, to monuments and museums and reenactments. There's President's Day and the fireworks that blast over George Washington's house every 4th of July. There are the Confederate flags and statues of Robert E. Lee that you don't want taken down.
我想对白人回应的是，你并没有忘掉过去。每年你们从全国各地涌向弗农山庄和其他类似的地方，涌向纪念碑、博物馆和重演活动。有总统日，有每年7月4日在乔治·华盛顿的故居上空炸响的烟花。有你们不想拆除的南方邦联旗帜和罗伯特·李（Robert E. Lee）的雕像。
No, I can't get over it. And neither can you. None of us can.
不，我忘不掉。你们也忘不掉。我们谁都忘不掉。
Azie Dungey. These days, she's a writer for Unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt and writing a book of essays about her experiences at Mount Vernon called How I Survived the 18th Century.
阿兹·邓吉。如今，她是《我本坚强》（Unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt）的编剧，正在写一本关于她在弗农山庄经历的文集，书名暂定为《我是如何从18世纪活下来的》。
[MUSIC - "WAKE UP" BY FUNKADELIC]
[音乐 - “WAKE UP” by FUNKADELIC]
Coming up, we warp from the past back to the future, to Daveed Diggs and an underwater world of tomorrow. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下里，我们将从过去跃迁回未来，去看看戴维德·迪格斯（Daveed Diggs）和明日的海底世界。那是芝加哥公共广播电台的节目，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "We Are in the Future," a show inspired by Afrofuturism, which my colleague Neil Drumming has become interested in as a lens to view the future, the past, and the present. Hey there, Neil.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。每周我们都会选择一个主题，带给你们关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“我们就在未来”，这是一个受非洲未来主义启发的节目，我的同事尼尔·德拉明一直对非洲未来主义很感兴趣，将其作为审视未来、过去和现在的镜头。嘿，尼尔。
Hello again. So in case you were wondering, the title of this week's show comes from an album by Sun Ra.
再次你好。顺便说一下，以防你好奇，这周节目的标题来自Sun Ra的一张专辑。
I am not wondering that, because I've sat in on our own story meetings. But continue and explain to the people.
我并不好奇，因为我旁听了我们自己的故事会议。但请继续，向大家解释一下。
Sorry. I didn't mean to black-splain you, Ira. So anyway-- so, the title for this week's show comes from an album by Sun Ra, We Are in the Future. He mostly did experimental jazz. That's what he's known for. But the piece we're going to play right now, "The Space Age is Here to Stay," is a little more gospel. It's a little more call and response.
抱歉。我不是故意要搞“黑人向我解释”（black-splain）那一套的，艾拉。所以……这周节目的标题来自Sun Ra的专辑《我们就在未来》（We Are in the Future）。他主要做实验爵士乐。这就是他为人所知的领域。但我们要播放的这首曲子，“太空时代将长存”，更偏福音，更偏呼应式演唱。
It's going to be like your ancestors said, even though they are cold and dead. Space age is here to stay. The space age is around to stay. Yeah, the space age is here to stay. Space age is here to stay.
就像你祖先所说的，即使他们已经冰冷且死去。太空时代将长存。太空时代将会留下。是的，太空时代将长存。太空时代将长存。
Which brings us to Act Three.
这把我们带到了第三幕。
Act Three, "The Black Sea."
第三幕，“黑海”。
So this one I know about. There's this hip hop group called clppng. that's Bill Hutson, Jonathan Snipes, and Daveed Diggs-- who, listeners might know, Daveed Diggs is on the soundtrack to Hamilton. He plays Lafayette and Thomas Jefferson.
这个我知道。有一个叫clppng.的嘻哈组合，成员是比尔·赫特森（Bill Hutson）、乔纳森·斯奈普斯（Jonathan Snipes）和戴维德·迪格斯——听众可能知道，戴维德·迪格斯是《汉密尔顿》（Hamilton）原声带的一员。他扮演拉法耶特和托马斯·杰斐逊。
And we commissioned clppng. to write a sci-fi story for us, a song. And what they made was a tribute to a Detroit band from the '90s called Drexciya. And Drexciya had created this whole mythology in their band. And the mythology was based on the idea that pregnant African women on slave ships were sometimes thrown overboard.
我们委托clppng.为我们写一个科幻故事，一首歌。他们创作的是对90年代底特律乐队Drexciya的致敬。Drexciya在他们的乐队中创造了整个神话。这个神话基于这样一个理念：怀孕的非洲女性在奴隶船上有时会被扔进海里。
And Drexciya imagined that the babies survived and learned to live and thrive underwater and that the babies founded a black Atlantis under the sea. And so in this song that clppng. wrote for us, the civilization under sea was living peacefully for centuries, unaware that humans were above on land until those of us who live on the surface, we intruded on their underwater civilization by firing seismic air cannons into their world looking for oil. And then they kind of slowly, over the course of the song-- you heard they slowly rise to the surface psyching up for war. So you'll hear the air cannons, you'll hear them come to the surface. Anyway, you'll hear it all. Here's the song.
Drexciya设想婴儿活了下来，学会了在水下生活和繁衍，并在海下建立了一个黑人的亚特兰蒂斯。所以在这首clppng.为我们写的歌里，海下的文明已经和平生活了几个世纪，直到那些居住在陆地上的人们不知情地向他们的世界发射地震空气炮寻找石油，侵犯了他们的水下文明。然后他们慢慢地，在歌的过程中——你听到了，他们慢慢升向水面，为战争做准备。所以你会听到空气炮的声音，你会听到他们来到水面。不管怎样，你们会听到一切。这是那首歌。
[MUSIC - "THE DEEP" BY CLPPNG.]
[音乐 - “THE DEEP” by CLPPNG.]
Y'all remember how deep it go. Start it from the bottom. Y'all remember how deep it go. Fore y'all had to come back.
你们都记得它有多深。从底部开始。你们都记得它有多深。在你们回来之前。
Deep. Y'all remember when it used to be deep. So deep. So so deep. When y'all swam up out your momma while your momma was asleep. So deep. So so deep.
深。你们都记得过去它有多深。如此深。如此、如此深。当你们在妈妈熟睡时从妈妈体内游出来的时候。如此深。如此、如此深。
And y'all remember when you had the dance floor lit. Dark. No two step. Deep. Y'all don't even sweat. Deep.
你们都记得舞池闪耀的时候。黑暗。没有两步舞。深。你们甚至不出汗。深。
As deep as it gets. Dreaming dead asleep and keeping time. Y'all heartbeat. Deep. Y'all heartbeat. Deep.
深不可测。做着死沉的梦并保持节奏。你们的心跳。深。你们的心跳。深。
And all the fishes had they eyes bugged out 'cause y'all dancing underwater, and y'all don't get wet. And the dark smells sweet. And y'all tails touch reef. Y'all feed off the bottom. But now y'all remember. Y'all remember. Y'all remember.
所有鱼儿都瞪大了眼睛，因为你们在水下跳舞，而且你们不会湿。黑暗闻起来很甜。你们的尾巴触碰礁石。你们以底部为食。但现在你们记得了。你们记得。你们记得。
Pressure outside the vehicle, 832.2 bars.
载具外压力，832.2巴。
Y'all remember when the deep got hot, when y'all moved on up, how y'all used to argue about the water getting warmer. Still y'all loved a little bit of light up in the deep. So deep. So so deep.
你们都记得当深海变热的时候，当你们向上移动时，你们如何争论水变得更暖。但你们仍然热爱深海中那一丁点光。如此深。如此、如此深。
Y'all remember saying how it couldn't be them two legs 'cause y'all came from two legs, and y'all mommas would have loved y'all if they could have breathed, but they wasn't ready for the deep. So deep. So so deep.
你们都记得说那不可能是那两条腿的人，因为你们来自两条腿，如果她们能呼吸的话，你们的妈妈会爱你们的，但她们还没准备好面对深海。如此深。如此、如此深。
Y'all remember when the first blast came. And the beat fell off. And the dreams got woke. And the light bent bad. And the fishes belly up. And them coral castles crumbled because they wasn't quite enough. And conversation used to break, like the floor quake, like the bleached bones.
你们都记得第一次爆炸发生的时候。节奏停止了。梦境惊醒了。光线弯曲得厉害。鱼儿翻了白肚。珊瑚城堡倒塌了，因为它们还不够坚固。对话也破碎了，像地动，像漂白的骨骼。
And the finned friends fled from they home. But the blast wouldn't stop, 'cause they wanted black gold. And them no gills had to feel it 'cause they couldn't be told. Y'all remember. Y'all remember.
鱼鳍朋友从家中逃走。但爆炸不会停止，因为他们想要黑金。那些没有腮的家伙不得不感受到它，因为他们听不进去。你们记得。你们记得。
Ocean salinity, 35 PSU. Water pH, 7.91.
海洋盐度，35 PSU。水质pH值，7.91。
Y'all remember when the regime change, that no please no calm seas let the water rise. So deep. So so deep.
你们都记得政权更迭的时候，没有平和，只有汹涌的海水让水位上涨。如此深。如此、如此深。
Oil slick upon the sleeper was an awful thing to realize. If the two legs want to wake the dead, they gon have to bring more fire. Y'all is closer to the earth. So deep.
油膜覆盖在沉睡者身上是一个可怕的现实。如果两条腿的家伙想唤醒死者，他们就得带来更多的火。你们离地球更近。如此深。
And y'all was talking how to get up in they heads and got to being real inspired. Circumstances of the birth has got you feeling like an army. Better yet a navy. And Dagon gave y'all the blessing. Now y'all going crazy. They live with green upon the surface, but they ain't deep.
你们在谈论如何进入他们的脑子里，并得到了真正的灵感。出生的环境让你们感觉像一支军队。或者说一支海军。大衮（Dagon）赐予了你们祝福。现在你们疯了。他们生活在水面的绿色中，但他们不深。
That pistol shrimp will knock a two leg off his feet. Y'all perfecting the steam void to rip up the ships. They using Sonar as second language. Y'all fluent with it. And all the dreamers is woke now and nightmares swim. But everybody heard that bloop, know y'all coming for them. Y'all remember. Y'all remember.
那只枪虾会把一个两条腿的家伙撞倒。你们正在完善蒸汽空洞来撕碎船只。他们用声纳作为第二语言。你们说得很流利。现在所有的梦想家都醒了，噩梦在游动。但每个人都听到了那声巨响，知道你们正冲着他们去。你们记得。你们记得。
Surface water temperature, 308 Kelvin.
表面水温，308开尔文。
Y'all remember when the call went out? No deep. No more deep. Sunshine.
你们都记得号角吹响的时候吗？没有深海。不再有深海。阳光。
Y'all remember feeling wind upon your skin? No deep. No more deep. Sunshine.
你们都记得皮肤感受到风的时候吗？没有深海。不再有深海。阳光。
Y'all remember how it burned in the beginning? No deep. No more deep. Ride on 'em. Ride on 'em. Ride on 'em.
你们都记得刚开始时它有多灼热吗？没有深海。不再有深海。碾压他们。碾压他们。碾压他们。
Y'all remember seeing sun across the surface on the day that y'all first came upon the water. So so deep. How the breaking of the surface showed the sky without a border, and the air was so much hotter. So so deep.
你们都记得你们第一次来到水面时看到阳光照耀在那里的那一天吗。如此、如此深。破碎的水面展示了没有边界的天空，空气是如此炎热。如此、如此深。
How the woke dreamers screamed and it rose tides. And the waves stretched up like a mountain high. And the no gills gasped, and they closed eyes. And they prayed to their gods and they asked why.
清醒的梦想家尖叫着，潮水上涨。海浪像山一样高高耸起。没有腮的家伙倒吸一口凉气，闭上了眼睛。他们向他们的神祈祷，问为什么。
And then y'all cried too, 'cause y'all recognized momma in the faces of the ones that y'all would terrorize. They were sisters and brothers. They were the babies born up out the water, not connected to each other, not a knowledge of the one drop. But they had to learn today. Y'all had one shot. Let the sun burn today. Let 'em feel the dark even deeper today. Make a two leg a believer today.
然后你们也哭了，因为你们在那些你们准备恐吓的人脸上认出了妈妈。他们是姐妹和兄弟。他们是从水中出生的婴儿，彼此没有关联，对那滴血脉一无所知。但他们今天必须学习。你们只有一次机会。让太阳今天燃烧吧。让今天的感觉更深沉吧。让一个两条腿的人今天成为信徒吧。
Let 'em know that they done woke a sleeper from a sleep. So deep. That y'all been dancing without any feet. So so deep. Is the nerve that they struck with the blast that they broke with the drill that they burnt with the gas.
让他们知道他们已经从睡梦中唤醒了一个沉睡者。如此深。你们在没有脚的情况下跳舞。如此、如此深。那是他们用爆炸震动的神经，用钻头破坏的，用气体焚烧的。
Y'all remember. So deep. Sunshine. Ride on 'em.
你们记得。如此深。阳光。碾压他们。
Y'all remember when y'all had to let 'em breathe. Ride on 'em.
你们记得当你们不得不让他们呼吸的时候。碾压他们。
Initiating tidal wave sequence, Uniform Romeo 030.
启动潮汐波序列，Uniform Romeo 030。
Daveed Diggs, with Bill Hutson and Jonathan Snipes, are clppng. clppng.'s latest album, about a slave ship in space, is called Splendor and Misery. Their website is the band's name, which is the word clipping without the vowels, clppng.com.
戴维德·迪格斯，与比尔·赫特森和乔纳森·斯奈普斯一起，组成了clppng.。clppng.关于一艘太空奴隶船的最新专辑名为《辉煌与苦难》（Splendor and Misery）。他们的网站是乐队的名字，也就是单词clipping去掉元音，clppng.com。
Act Four, "Childhood's End." Looking into Afrofuturism over the past few months, I found myself thinking about time and space a lot. Time, because so many of these stories involve people thinking about the past or the future or seeing the past and the future in the here and now. And space, because all of that time travel is cued by very specific places-- Detroit, or Mount Vernon, or Philadelphia, or wherever.
第四幕，“童年的终结”。在过去的几个月里探究非洲未来主义，我发现自己经常在思考时间和空间。时间，是因为这些故事中有太多涉及人们思考过去或未来，或者在此时此地审视过去和未来。空间，是因为所有的那些时间旅行都是由非常具体的地点所引发的——底特律、或弗农山庄、或费城，等等。
During those same months, I also became sort of obsessed with these two videos that I saw on YouTube. I couldn't help connecting them in my mind because for me, they were both about a particularly precious intersection of time and space. The time is that period when children have left school for the day but haven't yet made it home. And the space is that distance, however many blocks, however many miles it takes those kids to walk from one to the other. In other words, these two videos are about those moments when kids are out in the world on their own and the adults they bump into.
在同样的几个月里，我也变得有点沉迷于我在YouTube上看到的这两个视频。我忍不住在脑海中把它们联系起来，因为对我来说，它们都关于时间与空间一个特别珍贵的交集。时间是孩子们放学后但还没到家之前的那段时间。空间是那段距离，无论多少街区，无论多少英里，孩子们从那里走到家里所需的距离。换句话说，这两个视频是关于孩子们独自在世界徘徊，以及他们偶遇的成年人的时刻。
You may have seen the first video. It takes place in Atlantic City. Two black teenagers in sweatpants and sneakers are fighting in the middle of a residential street on their way home from school when a slightly older black man, Ibn Ali Miller, emerges from camera right and puts an end to the fight with a stern but passionate talking to.
你们可能看过第一个视频。它发生在大西洋城。两个穿着运动裤和运动鞋的黑人少年在放学回家的路上在一处居民区街道中间打架，这时稍微年长一点的黑人男子伊本·阿里·米勒（Ibn Ali Miller）从镜头右侧出现，用严厉但充满激情的一番话结束了这场争斗。
The clip went viral. Miller was honored by the city. Steve Harvey had him on his couch. I saw it for the first time on my Facebook feed this past winter, and then viewed it on YouTube many times since. It does not disappoint. It gets better every time I watch it.
这个片段在网上疯传。米勒受到了城市的表彰。史蒂夫·哈维（Steve Harvey）请他上了沙发。我是在去年冬天第一次在我的Facebook动态上看到它的，之后在YouTube上看了很多次。它没让人失望。我每次看都会觉得更好。
[KIDS TAUNTING, LAUGHING]
[孩子们嘲讽、大笑]
When it begins, the two boys grapple and flail at each other sloppily-- one tall, one chubby, both defiant. Other kids crowd around, recording with their cell phones, egging them on.
视频开始时，两个男孩笨拙地扭打在一起——一个高，一个胖，都充满挑衅。其他孩子围在周围，用手机录制，怂恿他们。
Square Up, go ahead, Brown.
对峙，来吧，布朗。
[KIDS TAUNTING, LAUGHING]
[孩子们嘲讽、大笑]
Then, seemingly out of nowhere, Miller bops into frame, his hands in his pockets, wearing work boots and a knit cap. He immediately starts to call out the kids who are recording.
然后，看似凭空，米勒走进了画面，手插在口袋里，穿着工装靴和针织帽。他立刻开始斥责那些正在录像的孩子们。
Everybody on your phones, though, all y'all, y'all the real cowards. Record that too. Everybody on the phone, record that. Everybody record on the phone, real coward.
所有拿着手机的，你们所有这些，你们才是真正的懦夫。把那也录下来。所有在手机上录像的，录下来。所有人在手机上录像，真正的懦夫。
Cowards, Miller calls them. Then he turns his attention to the two boys in the center.
懦夫，米勒这样称呼他们。然后他将注意力转向中间的两个男孩。
Listen, they all laughing, little brother. But you really upset. And you really upset. You more mad than he is, I can see it in your face. So you fighting for a reason. He only fighting you because you want to fight him.
听着，他们都在笑，小兄弟。但你真的很沮丧。你也很沮丧。你比他更生气，我能从你的脸上看出来。所以你是为了一个理由在打架。他只是因为你想打才打你。
No, he came to me. He touched me. I don't-- [BLEEP], I don't even know.
不，是他来找我。他碰了我。我不知道……[哔]，我甚至不知道。
So you defending yourself?
所以你在为自己辩护？
Yeah.
是的。
Miller listens. And then he tells the boys something they probably hadn't considered-- that they were most likely tricked into fighting by someone who thought it would be entertaining. And now all of their so-called friends are recording them go at it.
米勒听着。然后他告诉这两个男孩他们可能没考虑过的事情——他们极有可能是被某个觉得这会很有趣的人骗去打架的。现在他们所有所谓的“朋友”都在录下他们打斗的过程。
Look around. Who ill-advised you? Who told you wrong? Who told you wrong? You want to answer that? I'm saying, who told you wrong, little bro?
看看周围。谁给你出的烂主意？谁教错了你？谁教错了你？你想回答吗？我是说，谁教错了你，小兄弟？
And the only reason I'm saying this to all y'all, yo, because you're almost men. All y'all, yo. You're almost men. Y'all ain't kids no more. Y'all girls ain't little girls no more. Look, yo. Y'all men, yo. Y'all men, yo. 14, 15, 16, 17-- y'all men. Start acting like it, yo. We ain't gonna get nowhere like this, yo.
我之所以对你们所有人说这些，是因为你们快要成男人了。你们所有人。你们不再是小孩子了。你们女孩也不再是小女孩了。看着，喂。你们是男人，喂。你们是男人。14、15、16、17岁——你们是男人。开始像个男人一样行事吧，喂。我们这样下去哪儿也去不了，喂。
We ain't going to get nowhere like this, he says. Here, what Miller does that I love is steer the conversation away from personal grievances toward something bigger. He tries to tell these kids that they are part of a community. He tells them that their actions have consequences and that those consequences only get more serious as they get older. Without condescending to them, Miller talks to them about their futures.
我们这样下去哪儿也去不了，他说。米勒做的一件我最喜欢的事情就是将谈话从个人恩怨引导向更大的层面。他试图告诉这些孩子他们是一个共同体的一部分。他告诉他们，他们的行为有后果，而且随着年龄增长，这些后果只会更严重。没有对他们屈尊俯就，米勒与他们谈论他们的未来。
You think it's a game out here? Ain't no game out here. It's real out here, little bro. Word up. Don't make your parents look like this, yo. And if y'all live around here, y'all live somewhere good. Don't mess that up, bro.
你以为这只是游戏吗？这可不是游戏。这可是现实，小兄弟。听着。别让你父母看起来像这样，喂。如果你们住在这附近，你们住的是个好地方。别把它搞砸了，兄弟。
He's no longer just trying to get them to save face or avoid humiliation. He's warning the boys that as they become men, young black men, the world will become even more dangerous for them. Miller won't leave until the two shake hands. They don't want to at first. Only the chubby kid extends his hand.
他不再只是试图让他们保住面子或避免屈辱。他是在警告男孩们，随着他们成长为男人、年轻的黑人男子，世界对他们来说会变得更加危险。米勒不打算离开，直到两人握手言和。起初他们不想。只有胖男孩伸出了手。
Y'all gonna shake hands or I'm not leaving, bro. I'm not leaving, bro. Shake hands, bro.
你们握不握手？不然我不走，兄弟。我不走，兄弟。握手，兄弟。
Bro, just shake his hand, bro.
兄弟，就握他的手，兄弟。
The other kid doesn't. The chubby kid pulls his hand back.
另一个孩子没有握。胖男孩缩回了手。
Put your hand back out, bro. He gonna shake it this time, I promise you. Put your hand back out, bro. He gonna shake it, bro.
把手伸回去，兄弟。我保证他这次会握的。把手伸回去，兄弟。他会握的，兄弟。
He does.
他握了。
It's actually difficult for me to express how moved I was by this video. The beauty of it is that even while Miller is insisting that these teenagers become responsible for themselves, his actions demonstrate that they are not necessarily alone, that there is compassion and wisdom and guidance available to them. It was like a window into a world where people who don't know each other still give a damn, a window that I can rewind and rewatch and forward to my friends to click Like. It was at once exhilarating and comforting.
实际上，我很难表达我对这个视频有多感动。它的美妙之处在于，即使米勒坚持让这些少年对自己的行为负责，他的行为也证明了他们并非孤身一人，同情、智慧和指引是他们可以获取的。这就像是一扇通往某种世界的窗户，那里的人们即使互不相识也仍然关心彼此；这是一扇我可以倒带、重看，并转发给朋友点击“点赞”的窗户。它既让人兴奋又让人安慰。
I rode that high for a week, maybe two. Then another video popped up in my Facebook feed. This one is shakier and from a low angle, obviously recorded surreptitiously. The view is of the intersection of Bedford Avenue and Campus Road, Midwood High School on one side of the street, Brooklyn College is on the other. I recognized it immediately because I used to live 10 minutes away. There's still snow on the ground and the cell phone is buffeted about by wind.
我沉浸在那阵兴奋中持续了一周，也许两周。然后另一个视频出现在了我的Facebook动态上。这个视频镜头更晃，且角度很低，显然是偷偷录下的。视野是贝德福德大道（Bedford Avenue）和校园路（Campus Road）的交叉口，一边是米德伍德高中（Midwood High School），另一边是布鲁克林学院（Brooklyn College）。我立刻认出了它，因为我曾经住在10分钟路程外。地上还有雪，手机镜头被风吹得乱晃。
Its camera wobbles up behind two uniformed police officers walking slowly down Campus Road. The one on the left has both hands in his pockets. The one on the right has his baton already drawn. A handful of black teenagers walk obstinately before them, headed away toward Flatbush Avenue. There's no way to know for sure what happened before the video started rolling. There were, most likely, the beginnings of a snowball fight. But it's unclear who was unhappy about that.
镜头蹒跚地跟在两名缓慢走在校园路上的穿制服警察身后。左边的那个双手插在口袋里。右边的那个已经拔出了警棍。几个黑人少年正固执地走在他们前面，朝弗拉特布什大道（Flatbush Avenue）走去。无法确定视频开始录制前发生了什么。极有可能是打雪仗的开始。但不清楚是谁对那感到不满。
The police were not called. They were already onsite. In the footage, one of the cops says, come on, let's go, though the kids are already going. The cop on the right reaches out. It looks like he shoves a boy in a pink hoodie. The boy flinches, snapping his head around.
警察不是被叫来的。他们就在现场。镜头中，其中一名警察说：来吧，走吧，尽管孩子们已经在走了。右边的警察伸出手。看起来他推了一个穿着粉色卫衣的男孩。男孩畏缩了一下，猛地转过头。
Stop touching me, he says. The cop responds with, what are you going to do about it-- which is obnoxious and a stupid question. But that doesn't stop him from asking it at least five more times, like a kid taunting another kid.
别碰我，他说。警察回应道：你要干什么——这很讨厌，是个愚蠢的问题。但他还是坚持问了至少五次，就像一个孩子在嘲弄另一个孩子。
What are you going to do about it? What are you going to do about it? What are you going to do about it? What are you going to do about it? What are you going to do about it?
你要干什么？你要干什么？你要干什么？你要干什么？你要干什么？
At one point, one of the teenagers fires back, that's why we out. It sounds bad ass. But if you think about it, the kid is saying, we're walking away because we can't do anything about it. And we all know that. Another kid in the procession kneels down to pick up some snow. With his left hand, the cop on the right pulls his taser out of his holster and barks--
在某个时刻，其中一名少年回嘴：这就是为什么我们要走。这听起来很酷。但如果你仔细想想，那个孩子是在说：我们走开是因为我们什么也做不了。我们都知道这一点。行列中的另一个孩子跪下来抓起一些雪。左手拿着警棍的警察从枪套里掏出泰瑟枪（Taser），并咆哮着——
Pick that [BLEEP] up again. Pick that [BLEEP] up again.
再捡起那个[哔]东西试试。再捡起那个[哔]东西试试。
Pick that [BLEEP] up again. Rock, paper, scissors, snowball, taser. The kids keep walking away. The cop yells, pick that [BLEEP] up again, one more time, and follows with--
再捡起那个[哔]东西试试。石头、剪刀、布，打雪仗，泰瑟枪。孩子们继续走开。警察大喊：再捡起那个[哔]东西试试，又来了一次，接着说——
You want to ride the lightning?
你想尝尝被电击的滋味吗？
Do you want to ride the lightning? The video ends as the kids cross the street to safety and the cops stop on the corner. I know. I know it seems like you can see worse, more unjust things happen to black people on YouTube just about any day of the week. Here, fortunately, no one was hurt.
你想尝尝被电击的滋味吗？视频在孩子们横穿街道去到安全地带时结束，警察停在路口。我知道。我知道这看起来好像你几乎每天在YouTube上都能看到针对黑人更糟糕、更不公正的事情发生。在这里，幸运的是，没人受伤。
But this video was still hard to watch, especially having seen how Ibn Ali Miller talked those kids down in Atlantic City. Whereas Miller was trying to get the teenagers to think a little bit more like adults, the cop in this video sounded like a teenager himself, bullying and provoking. What's worse, he almost seemed to be enjoying it. It's hard to imagine he cared anything at all about what happened to those kids after they deserted that corner.
但这个视频仍然很难看，尤其是看过伊本·阿里·米勒在大西洋城的视频中如何开导那些孩子之后。米勒试图让少年们像成年人一样多思考一点，而这个视频里的警察听起来像个少年自己，欺凌和挑衅。更糟的是，他看起来甚至很享受这一切。很难想象他会关心这些孩子离开那个角落后会怎样。
I told my friends about this video too. I sent the link around. It wasn't as popular a clip as the one with Miller. I read everything I could about it. I found out that the kids most likely went to Midwood High School. And a few weeks later, I went to Midwood High School and stood on the corner of Bedford Avenue and Campus Road. I wanted to find someone who had witnessed the incident. I was angry on behalf of those young men, and I wanted to know how they felt. I found one of them immediately, and then the others found me.
我也告诉了朋友关于这个视频的事。我发了链接。它不如米勒的那个片段那么受欢迎。我读了关于它的所有报道。我发现这些孩子很有可能就读于米德伍德高中。几周后，我去了米德伍德高中，站在贝德福德大道和校园路的路口。我想找到一个目击事件的人。我为那些年轻人感到愤怒，我想知道他们的感受。我立刻找到了其中一个，然后其他人找到了我。
Wait, which one were you?
等等，你是哪一个？
Me? I was the black kid.
我？我是那个黑人小孩。
Well, they were all black kids.
好吧，他们都是黑人小孩。
I was the blackest one, the tallest one.
我是最黑的那个，最高的那个。
They're in tapered gray sweats and colorful napsacks. They told me they came to this spot almost every day, bought chicken and fries and rice, slap boxed with each other, kicked it with girls, and waited for the rest of their crew to go play basketball down the block. They wanted to know what my microphone was for and if they could get money and girls from being on the radio, and if I could buy them lunch.
他们穿着紧身灰运动裤和彩色背包。他们告诉我，几乎每天都来这个地方，买鸡肉、薯条和米饭，互相打闹，和女孩们混在一起，等待他们小团队里的其他人去街区那边打篮球。他们想知道我的麦克风是做什么的，上广播能不能拿到钱和结识女孩，以及我能不能给他们买午饭。
I asked them what they were doing on the day that the video was recorded. One of them said he was cutting class. Others said they weren't. I asked them why they think the cops came, since their high school has its own security. One of them said that some other kids across the street were throwing snow and the cops thought it was us. One of the boys said it was them. But still, it was only snowballs.
我问他们视频录制那天在做什么。其中一个说他在逃课。其他人说没有。我问他们为什么认为警察会来，因为他们的中学有自己的保安。其中一个说街对面的其他孩子在扔雪球，警察以为是我们。其中一个男孩说是他们。但归根结底，那只是雪球。
We were just being kids. We was being kids, chilling.
我们只是像孩子一样。我们只是孩子，在闲逛。
Yeah, and they was just wilding out.
是的，他们只是在发疯。
Even though I was snowballing. Even though I was snowballing.
尽管我当时在玩雪球。尽管我当时在玩雪球。
Yeah, we were just doing what we was doing. And we were just having fun.
是的，我们只是在做我们的事，我们只是在玩得开心。
I asked if they were scared when it happened. A couple of 16-year-olds, cooler than I had ever been at that age, said, no, not really. A 14-year-old said, emphatically, of course. He was 6' 2, my height.
我问他们发生那事时是否感到害怕。几个16岁的少年，比我那个年纪时酷得多，说，不，没真的怕。一个14岁的男孩强调说，当然怕。他有6英尺2英寸高，和我一样高。
I was surprised at how tall some of the boys were, none of them older than 16. I was also surprised at how not angry they seemed. I grew up about 45 minutes from here in a similar neighborhood in Queens, not so long ago, I thought. But when I asked them why they thought this had happened to them at all, one of the older boys talked to me like he was explaining why humans need food. The cop was white.
我很惊讶其中一些男孩长得那么高，没一个超过16岁。我也很惊讶他们看起来一点也不愤怒。我想，我长大的地方离这大约45分钟路程，在皇后区一个类似的社区，没多久前。但当我问他们为什么认为这事会发生在他们身上时，其中一个大一点的男孩跟我说话的口吻就像在解释为什么人类需要食物一样。警察是白人。
You know they don't like black people. And I thought-- I was like, oh, we about to [IMITATING TASER].
你知道他们不喜欢黑人。我想……我当时就像，哦，我们要[模仿泰瑟枪声]。
Yeah, we about to get tased.
是的，我们要被电击了。
Maybe this is just me, but I look back on walks home from school as my first real flirtations with independence, a sacred time and space between my teachers' rules and my parents' restrictions. The kids in that video, this was their school. This was their neighborhood. Most of the ones I talked to live only four or five blocks away. As far as they were concerned, this was their corner. I can't imagine what it would feel like to be firmly in your time and space and run up against a cop with a taser, threatening to electrocute you if you don't put down that snowball.
也许这只是我的想法，但我回顾放学回家的路，把它看作我第一次真正的独立启蒙，在老师的规矩和父母的限制之间有一段神圣的时间和空间。那个视频里的孩子们，那是他们的学校。这是他们的社区。我交谈过的绝大多数孩子只住四五个街区远。据他们所知，这是他们的地盘。我无法想象坚定地处于自己的时间和空间里，却遇到一个拿着泰瑟枪的警察，威胁如果你不放下雪球就电击你，会是什么感觉。
What's crazier to me is that I've walked through this intersection at Bedford Avenue and Campus Road, past the high school, and through the Brooklyn College campus many times in the last few years. Beneath its landmark-gilded clocktower, Brooklyn College could be a campus quad from a corny 1950s film, except teeming with students from cultures all over New York. Something about it practically screams "welcome, things only get better from here."
更让我疯狂的是，过去几年里，我多次走过贝德福德大道和校园路的那个路口，走过高中，穿过布鲁克林学院的校园。布鲁克林学院在那座地标性的镀金钟楼之下，可能像是来自一部庸俗的1950年代电影的校园广场，只是挤满了来自纽约各地的文化背景的学生。关于它的一些东西几乎在尖叫着“欢迎，从这里开始，一切只会变得更好”。
The young black men in that video came out of their high school that day and stood at the edge of that promise. What could be the next great space and time in their lives was a college literally across the street, but they were shooed away, told they didn't belong. As far as metaphors go, this one couldn't be less ambiguous.
视频里那些年轻的黑人男子那天走出高中，站在那个承诺的边缘。他们生活中下一个伟大的时间和空间可能就是 literalmente 马路对面的大学，但他们被赶走了，被告知他们不属于这里。作为隐喻，这一点也不含糊。
But none of this seemed to bother the boys, or at least not that they let on. This was not the first time that they had been made to feel unwelcome so close to home and school. Yet they weren't festering with resentment. They weren't seeing the tragedy in it that I was seeing.
但这似乎并没有困扰这些男孩，或者至少他们没有表现出来。这不是他们第一次在离家和学校这么近的地方感到不受欢迎。然而，他们并没有怀着怨恨。他们并没有看到我所看到的其中的悲剧。
After I finished talking to them, I went across the street to find the Brooklyn College professor who had recorded the incident. Alex Vitale teaches sociology and also happens to run the school's policing and social justice project. Leaving work that day, he'd seen the two cops descend on Bedford Avenue on Campus Road, followed them, and it was his recording that ended up on YouTube, as well as a few local news websites.
谈话结束后，我穿过马路去寻找那个录制事件的布鲁克林学院教授。亚历克斯·维塔莱（Alex Vitale）教授社会学，也恰好负责学校的警务和社会正义项目。那天离开工作场所时，他看到两名警察降临到贝德福德大道和校园路，就跟了上去，而他的录音最终出现在了YouTube以及一些当地新闻网站上。
We talked briefly about how repeated incidents like this could affect the boys' psyches. He agreed that no matter how cool they seem now, over time, their hopes for their own futures could possibly darken. But then Alex asked me how old I was. When I told him 43, he said that I had missed the height of the stop and frisk era. I was not a teenager or even a young man in New York City when unprompted police harassment was at its worst.
我们简短地谈论了像这样反复发生的事件会如何影响男孩们的心理。他同意，无论他们现在看起来多酷，随着时间的推移，他们对自己未来的希望可能会变暗。但随后亚历克斯问我多大了。当我告诉他43岁时，他说我错过了“拦截搜身”（stop and frisk）时代的巅峰。我在纽约市警察骚扰最严重的时候不是少年，甚至不是年轻人。
So the taser incident outraged me. But what these kids had seen their older brothers, sisters, and in some cases parents go through had conditioned them to be a bit more stoic. It stung a little bit to have this white academic tell me that I couldn't quite relate to a young black man's experience. I guess when I first approached those boys, a part of me hoped that, like Ibn Ali Miller in the Atlantic City video, I would just roll up out of nowhere and know everything about their world that they know, plus some more. Instead, I was just another adult, taking their time and invading their space.
所以那个泰瑟枪事件让我愤怒。但这些孩子亲眼目睹了他们的哥哥、姐姐，在某些情况下还有父母所经历的事情，这让他们变得更加坚忍。让这个白人学者告诉我我无法完全理解年轻黑人的经历，让我有点刺痛。我想，当我第一次接近那些男孩时，我的一部分希望，就像大西洋城视频里的伊本·阿里·米勒一样，我会突然出现，并且了解他们世界里的一切，甚至更多。相反，我只是另一个大人，占用了他们的时间，侵犯了他们的空间。
[MUSIC - "GOOD TO YOUR EARHOLE" BY FUNKADELIC]
[音乐 - “GOOD TO YOUR EARHOLE” by FUNKADELIC]
Well, our program was produced today by Neil Drumming and Stephanie Foo. Our staff includes Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Kimberly Henderson, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, BA Parker, Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed.
好了，我们的节目今天由尼尔·德拉明和斯蒂芬妮·福（Stephanie Foo）制作。我们的团队包括苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、惠特尼·丹格菲尔德（Whitney Dangerfield）、金伯利·亨德森（Kimberly Henderson）、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）、赛斯·林德（Seth Lind）、BA·帕克（BA Parker）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和戴安·吴（Diane Wu）。我们的资深制作人是布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）。
Special thanks to Frank Nieto, Nalo Hopkinson, Detroit Robinson, Shani Hilton, Nailah Middleton, Steve Kaplan, Stephen Henderson, Lee DeVito, Solange Franklin, Evan Narcisse, Bryce Detroit, Xiomara, and Denmark Vessey. Our website, with this music video to go with the clppng. underwater sci-fi song you heard earlier, also the artist Paul Davey did a piece of original art for today's show, that's thisamericanlife.org.
特别感谢弗兰克·涅托（Frank Nieto）、纳洛·霍普金森（Nalo Hopkinson）、底特律·罗宾逊（Detroit Robinson）、沙尼·希尔顿（Shani Hilton）、奈拉·米德尔顿（Nailah Middleton）、史蒂夫·卡普兰（Steve Kaplan）、斯蒂芬·亨德森（Stephen Henderson）、李·德维托（Lee DeVito）、索兰格·富兰克林（Solange Franklin）、埃文·纳西斯（Evan Narcisse）、布莱斯·底特律（Bryce Detroit）、希奥马拉（Xiomara）和丹麦·维西（Denmark Vessey）。我们的网站，有你们刚才听到的clppng.水下科幻歌曲的音乐录影带，还有艺术家保罗·戴维（Paul Davey）为今天的节目创作的原画，网址是thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who had the most disappointing latte of his entire life this week. He asked for extra foam, extra cream, but it did not come that way.
《美国生活》通过公共广播交流中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生，他这周喝了他人生中最令人失望的拿铁。他要了额外的奶泡和奶油，但结果并不是那样。
It was, like, 110% black. It was super-black. It was just black.
它就像，110%黑人。它超级黑。它就是黑人。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。